Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allchech.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
the chapter regarding the merits and
rulings and
details of patience.
He first mentions the last verse of
surah al the third chapter of the Quran.
It's the chapter in which Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala ends all of the
lessons of Ali Imran
and surah Ali Imran is one of the
greatest chapters of the Quran.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam very
often mention it alongside bakar
and it has a lot of merits that are
proprietary to it.
However, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala ends
all of those lessons
in Alan
by saying that which translates to, "Oh
you who have believed,
be patient
and
out patient," which is is a strange
word. I'm not even sure is a real word,
but that's what it would translate to.
So
the difference between
means be patient
means to be more patient than your
opposition.
means be more patient than your enemy.
And this is
very very critical not just in the
physical battle battlefield.
However, in the battlefield against any
enemy,
it is not who
is patient
who wins. It is whoever is more patient
even if only by a moment
even only one moment more patient
that is how a battle and ultimately a
war is won
and so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is commanding the believers oh you who
have believed so these are traits of
believers here
This is something which is specific to
believers.
The believers are most
required, most expected
of these traits. Be patient
and be more patient than your enemy.
And so
patience with an enemy is part of
patience. However, it warrants being
mentioned
specifically.
[Silence]
What is patience with an enemy look
like?
a very famous story a very known
well-known story that is you know it's
mentioned oftentimes by the scholars of
Islam
regarding an ancient pre-Islamic
Jahi warrior
who was
called Ant
was a you know a major figure in
pre-Islamic Arabia he was a known poet
and he was a known warrior known for his
valor and his courage and
and he was viewed often as undefeated
and all of these legends surrounded
Antra.
And a man once asked him,
"How are you able to defeat every enemy
that you step toe-to-toe with?" It's
amazing. It's incredible how what's your
secret.
So, Antar said, "I will show you."
And so, he took the man's finger
and put it in his between his teeth in
his mouth.
And then he put his the tip of his
finger in the man's teeth
and he said, "Bite down as hard as you
can."
And so as soon as they both bit down on
each other's finger, the other man
submitted immediately.
He submitted immediately. He wailed out.
Stop. He tapped out right away.
And so Anto said just that,
had you not screamed, I was about to
scream from pain,
but I looked at you and I saw you hadn't
screamed yet. So I thought to myself, I
could push it one more moment. One more
moment.
This is how battles are won. You don't
have to win
by a landslide.
That's good. That's great for morale.
But ultimately, you just have to be on
your feet a moment longer than your
enemy.
This, of course,
physically plays out on the
battlefield.
However,
on the spiritual battlefield, it is no
different. What do we mean it is no
different? Who is our greatest enemy in
the Quran? Ell
is the human being sworn em enemy while
Adam
was still a husk of clay.
We were already marked by our enemy El.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us throughout the Quran
that he is your enemy.
So treat him as such he is your enemy.
Behave with him as you do with an enemy.
And the enemy
who is determined
is the dangerous enemy. It's not a
powerful enemy. It's not an enemy with
more means.
It is an enemy who has determination.
Because
at the end of everything, when you break
everything down to its most elemental
level,
all combat, spiritual or physical,
is a test of wills.
It's a test of wills. Who has more will?
That's all.
And so
your sworn enemy is incredibly
determined.
He has a lot of means and he has
innumerable soldiers
and they are growing every day their
numbers.
Not only that, but
we're at a physical disadvantage
because he can see us but we can't see
him as Allah tells us. However,
if a person is fighting against an enemy
that outpowers him,
overpowers him,
then is there any blame on that person?
A person who fights valiantly
but ultimately loses because his enemy
was more powerful.
Can a person be held accountable for
that? The answer is no.
No.
Because a person who fights to his
maximum ability and is overpowered by
his enemy, he's done what is he is
obligated to do, what's expected of him.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that no soul shall be burdened or is
burdened by more than it can bear.
So then on the day of judgment when
people come and they have been brought
to their knees by their enemy,
why then are they going to be put into
the fire of hell? Why are they held
accountable for losing their battle
withl? Why
that the people of hell who will be
dumped and toppled head over heels into
the fire
are
the disbelievers.
the
misguided
El and his troops.
The question still stands. A person goes
to war with an entity, an enemy more
powerful than himself and loses. How can
you blame someone? Yes, you can only
blame him if he had the ability to win
and all the tools to win but still lost.
Our enemy El is very weak.
He is not more powerful than the Muslim.
He does not have nearly the abilities of
the Muslim.
Els
are his lies and his whispers and his
people that obey him. That's it.
He cannot compel or bring a believer to
his knees. A believer must want to be on
his knees to be brought to his knees
byl.
This is why people who obey ell will be
punished and held to account by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
You have the Quran.
You have the sunnah.
You have the intellect.
You have everything. You have your
brothers. You have everything that you
need in order to win your battle with El
yet you still lost. Why?
And so
this is something that is very important
for us to understand. A lot of times
when we start to think about the
abilities of El say wow this creature
has been around for a millennium.
He has all the tricks in the bag. He has
all the knowledge,
all the history,
and billions and billions of troops
and lies.
How can we ever hope to win such a
battle? You have the Quran,
the literal words of Allah. And not only
that, but Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells you if you start to lose your
breath, seek refuge in me and I'll give
you a chance to get back on your knees.
Yet in spite of that, we are seduced.
Which takes us to the real cause of
being seduced by a shaitan. What is the
real cause?
The real cause of being seduced
is that a person can only be seduced if
they want to be.
It is impossible to seduce someone who
does not want to be seduced truly.
It is only when
second-guessing and fear and so forth
is sparked in the heart of the person
that they're able to be led astray by
El.
And so there is not a single thing thatl
does or ever will do, not one trick, not
one lie that he will tell that we can't
find in the Quran.
How is it that we are able to know whatl
says from what Allah says? All these
things going on in our mind. How do we
know which voice isl?
Because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala told us what
he says. He didn't tell us what he
sounds but he told us what he
would say and what he does say.
So, how do you protect yourself? You
seek refuge in Allah and you learn the
book of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Anything
that
is the words of a shan as outlined by
Allah in the Quran immediately no matter
how good it sounds no matter how logical
it sounds no matter how it's right there
you know immediately this is a shaitan
but a human being who doesn't know what
Allah said who doesn't know what his
prophet said a human being who's left
his at his own devices to try to fight
against an enemy and he is blind and an
enemy that uses logic and argument and
debate.
I feel very you must feel sad and bad
for a person a human being who is trying
to fight his demons without the book of
Allah. It's almost impossible to be able
to make heads or tails of such an
encounter.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and
I meanham.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.